[Music]
if we were to ever encounter alien life
would we be able to recognize it as life
at all if an organism lived and breathed
like animals on earth we'd certainly
identify it as alive but what if some
aliens don't look like organic life as
we know it or aren't organic in the
first place a project that expands the
horizons of what life on other planets
might look like is the teeming universe
an interstellar field guide by
speculative author and artist christian
klein this book which i have a link to
down below is one i've covered a section
of before on this channel on our
previous expedition through the cosmos
we saw all manner of incredible species
and learned about the science behind
them for this entry into the archive
we'll be journeying on a deep space
vessel called the peregrine to even more
extreme environments
we'll start with planets where the
organisms are truly strange and as we
continue
we'll reach places where we might need a
whole new definition of life
in a far-flung corner of the galaxy our
first stop is a planet shrouded in a
haze of dust this is aite an extreme
world with continent-sized dust storms
that keep the surface in near permanent
twilight
stepping out onto the surface we find a
shadow world plants on ait possess black
leaves to absorb as much of the sun's
energy as possible and animals have
gotten even more creative to adapt the
low light the first life form we
encounter on our voyage is a hella renee
a wolf sized ambush predator that stalks
the dim grasslands in search of prey but
what's most unusual about the heller
rene is that unlike almost all animals
they possess three eyes two on the side
and a massive one in the middle this
might seem far-fetched yet certain
species of real amphibians and reptiles
possess tiny photoreceptive eyes called
solar eyes in the center of their head
these third eyes aren't as complex as
their primary ones but are excellent at
detecting light so it's likely that the
hellerenne's third eye began as solar
eye spots but due to planet aeite's
dimness became their dominant visual
organ
and other animals on aite have followed
this trend the sconics are moose-sized
galloping herbivores that share the
ait's three-eyed setup with two eyes
having moved to the side to keep watch
for predators the sconex graze in large
family herds digging vegetation from the
ground with their wedge-shaped beaks and
ready to dart at the first sign of
trouble in many ways these majestic
animals are the wild horses of these
planes
a somewhat less majestic life form is
the sand pig these round near-sighted
animals spend their time shuffling along
the plains foraging for the worm-like
creatures they prefer to feed on these
burrowing animals spend much of their
time tunneling snugly underground only
surfacing in the low light of dawn to
shuffle over and visit the burrows of
other sand pigs and i have to say i'm a
huge fan of these round creatures as we
climb back aboard our spaceship a trio
of baby helerene's watcher departure
these infants are called pupples and
they're far less menacing than their
carnivorous parents they show us that
although aite is a planet of dust and
dimness the beauty of life can still
take hold
from orbit our next planet solis is a
shimmering jewel of the cosmos an
earth-sized temperate paradise with a
healthy atmosphere and glistening seas
landing on the planet's surface it's a
balmy summer day yet despite the
seemingly ideal conditions there's not
as much terrestrial life on this planet
as one might expect look to the sky and
the reason becomes clear planet's lease
has no moon the lack of a moon might not
seem important to a planet's
habitability but moons can help
stabilize a planet's axial tilt keeping
the weather and temperature more
predictable which is essential to the
development of life the push and pull of
a moon's gravity also helps produce
intertidal zones regions that are key
for life to transition from water to
land for this reason it is probable that
most habitable planets in our universe
have at least one orbiting moon yet some
organisms have hauled themselves onto
the surface of solis all the same this
is santhir one of the planet's largest
land animals in a testament to the
stubbornness of evolution these odd
segmented creatures still live their
lives tied to the ocean as they have to
lay their eggs in the water like many
species of earth amphibians like frogs
they also have to keep their skin wet to
aid in respiration as sand ears don't
have fully functional terrestrial lungs
their burrows are reflective of their
dual lifestyle with both aquatic and
terrestrial entrances these nesting
grounds show that sand theirs are
surprisingly talented homemakers much
like beavers the semi-aquatic home
building champions of our own planet
these nests are vital when the weather
shifts planet salisa's unstable moonless
axial tilt means the climate is highly
variable with some regions frequently
buffeted by cyclones but not all
creatures fear the storm
this small lifeform is called a bihari
flyer and as its name suggests it's one
of the rare life forms on salis that has
managed to leave the water for the air
due to the intense weather these
creatures have rather extreme patterns
of migrations moving to the equator in
late spring to escape the raging summer
winds yet to the south it's a beautiful
clear night this planet is an incredible
testimony to life's persistence but it's
time we set off to our next destination
the next stop on our journey promises to
be an unforgettable one from space it is
clear that planet cralon is the site of
massive artificial engineering projects
it seems we have at last found advanced
alien life yet upon the surface
everything is quiet aside from sparse
colonies of bacteria
on the poles no biological life
whatsoever is present on this planet
instead these silent cities are ruled by
what we might term artificial life
a great hivemind of machines preside
over this planet which leaves one to
wonder where their makers have gone
perhaps the creators of this ai left the
planet for better prospects or perhaps
they died at the hands of their own
artificial creations and this desolate
world is the site of a mass grave
or is it these machines called the crail
might not fit our traditional standards
of life but they are at such a level of
advancement in interconnectivity they
could almost be considered an ecosystem
and an ecosystem can be studied at the
base of this highly unusual environment
are scouts small 2-3 foot drones scouts
appear to be in charge of finding
regions in the system to mine for
materials to make more crail these
mining operations are massive as the
machines have almost completely hollowed
out a neighboring moon the energy needed
to complete these operations is possible
thanks to another important life form so
to speak these crawl machines are solar
panels 600 foot long power collectors
which orbit the sun and transmit vital
energy to other machines this division
of labor means the crayol collective
function almost like a beehive
and the queens of this colony are the
archships by far the largest type of
machine archships are 20 miles or 32
kilometers in length
overall arc ships seem to function like
neurons in a brain constantly beaming
untranslatable information to other
machines and to each other indeed it's
possible that the entire crayola society
is better understood as a single solar
system spanning life form all with a
single goal
but what is this goal
are the creole mining for their own
purposes or are they merely following a
preset path
still active from countless years ago
fears of evil robots aside they don't
seem to be actively malicious yet at the
same time we might feel safer once we've
left this system but are cold machines
the only type of intelligence we'll find
on our journey our next stop is tavari
and from space we can see light shining
on the surface is this the glow of a
kindred civilization or something else
the only way to find out is to get
closer making our descent we find tavari
is much like other habitable planets we
visited save for one major difference
tivati isn't actually a planet at all
but a moon orbiting a gas giant similar
to jupiter and this moon is considerably
smaller than earth with a fraction of
the gravity and without the constraints
of a strong gravitational pull life on
this moon can become gigantic this is a
tevet a creature which at 30 feet or
nine meters tall wouldn't be able to
stand up on earth but they're perfect
for tavare where they spend their time
grazing on the tops of tall trees
meaning their lifestyle is similar to a
giraffe's yet tevets would tower over a
giraffe of earth which is why it's lucky
for us these titans are gentle giants
and with their vaguely humanoid body
plan is it possible that these are our
light makers it doesn't seem so for
while the tevans aren't unintelligent
they're a long way from civilization
building
here at last on the horizon we can
glimpse immense technological structures
these gleaming wonders are home to a
sapient biological species the first
ever encountered apart from ourselves
meet the yatuans a hexapod species that
don't look much like us at a glance but
have all the necessary ingredients for
high intelligence possessing both a
highly developed brain and manipulatory
appendages with two opposable thumb-like
structures yetuans are kindred spirits
in the story of evolution indeed they've
been at this for longer and are quite a
bit more advanced technologically than
we are and luckily for us are quite
friendly
translating their messages we learn
their buildings on tavaty are just small
colonies the yaetuan's planet of origin
is far more inspiring
with our new friends in tow we've
arrived at the yaetuan home world the
final destination of our interstellar
expedition this is yetu the gleaming
center of a network of yetun's
settlements that spans many star systems
landing in the middle of a bustling
metropolis we can see yaichuan citizens
going about their lives like a colony of
ants yetuans are more communal than
humans and seem to live in remarkable
harmony but it wasn't always this way
like us yaichuans have a long and
complicated past stretching from
hunter-gatherers to an industrial era
where the yetuans pushed their planet to
ecological collapse due to environmental
neglect
it is for this reason that yetuans fled
to build colonies on other planets in
mass exodus
today the billions of yatuans call
different worlds home and over thousands
of years have become subtly different
from each other both in language and
appearance
now however their society is
reconnecting as they've restored their
homeworld's environment using their
advanced technology
while the modern ecosystem of planet
yeh2 is of course dominated by the
yetuans there are other notable native
lifeforms worth discussing
the wetim are a native species of pack
hunters which have a close relationship
to the yatuans like humans and our own
canine companions the wetum are the
domestic dogs of planet yetu having been
selected for thousands of years to be
friendly and sociable
another culturally important animal are
the walteth four winged fliers that play
a vital role in pollinating plant life
on yehu including yetuan crops as a
result the etuwons encourage their
presence constructing artificial nests
on the sides of modern buildings to
ensure the cities don't disrupt their
habitat the yaetuan species is an
incredible story of redemption in many
ways the yaichuwan's journey from
planetary collapse to restoration is one
worth reflecting on will humanity repeat
their mistakes or learn from their
example only time will tell meeting and
communing with the yeti ones has been a
very special experience but now the time
has come for us to return home
we've seen much on our epic journey
through the stars
yet christian klein's book the teeming
universe contains many more speculative
worlds and alien creatures and i
encourage you to check out the link to
it below and part 1 of this series and
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
[Music]
you